the final villain in mha has just been
revealed and no it's not all for one he
will destroy the hero Society on his own
terms and that includes not only the
heroes but even all for one himself as
Deku braces for the newly awakened
tomuro shigaraki to unleash all of his
many quirks at full power the final
battle reaches a new deadly phase so
let's get into it and just a reminder
that over 50 of you guys who watch our
videos are not subscribed to the channel
do me a huge favor and subscribe right
now it's completely free but it helps me
out a lot now a quick thank you to Mech
arena for sponsoring this video I always
fantasized about riding a Mecca like
they do in Gundam or Code Geass but
unfortunately anime is not reality at
least not yet thankfully with Macarena I
can now get the experience of operating
my own Mecca from my smartphone Macarena
is a competitive and strategy based team
shooter where you can play 2v2 or 5v5
you can also create your own custom
matches and invite friends to play with
or you can take on the competition in
Epic in-game tournaments my favorite
part of this game is the wide variety of
game modes from capture to point to
straight up 2v2 or 5v5 elimination this
allows me to switch things up so I never
get bored of playing in terms of mechs I
love using surge it's a very Speedy Mech
which allows you to quickly capture
points and along with its EMP ability
it's just super fun to use and very
effective I also love the polar blue
skin it's super cool what are you
waiting for install Macarena on mobile
or PC using my personal link or this QR
code on screen and you will get a free
starter pack worth thirty dollars it
includes a rocket mortar 6 on amateur
crate and a skin to help kick-start your
game try it out for yourself click the
link in the description or scan the QR
code to download Macarena right now and
if you're quick find me in game via my
Mech ID 510-40463
finally this video will contain Boku no
hero manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned in the
last chapter we saw the Epic return of
two former villains gentle and Lady
Nagant both of them have now switched
sides largely thanks to their individual
meetings with Deku and both of them
played a key role in Saving everyone at
UA from imminent destruction gentle
saved the entire compound from crashing
to the ground and Nagant saved everyone
from shigaraki's Decay by shooting off
one of his hands and with everything
that's been happening on the battlefield
lately the heroes definitely needed some
major reinforcements and that is exactly
what they got but at the same time the
real tomurashigaraki finally managed to
emerge from all for one's control and
regain the power over his own body this
is clearly not the scenario that all for
one himself had been hoping for he was
planning to take complete control of
shigaraki by now and just turned him
into a vessel for his own Consciousness
now that shigaraki is successfully
resisting that control a major internal
conflict begins as we know all for one
already gave up on his original Body by
using rewind on it because he thought
that shigaraki was already under his
control he knew that using rewind would
eventually destroy his original body but
that didn't matter to him because he
could simply move his Consciousness into
shigaraki and live on but now that
shigaraki has regained control all for
one will be desperate to reclaim his
vessel before his time runs out all for
one is not a quitter so we know that an
epic final battle is about to ensue one
that pits full power shigaraki against
full power Deku but also a fight between
the will of shigaraki and the will of
one for all this is the battle that will
have both external and and internal
Dimensions the latest chapter starts off
with an explanation of how Lady Nagant
ended up on the UA Battlefield after
being injured by that explosion she was
held at the Central Hospital the same
place where kurogiri had also been kept
now lady Nagant was being held there as
an injured prisoner but after kurogiri
was broken out and Chaos ensued she also
made a break for it Dr Super Mario ran
after her and warned her that she
shouldn't be moving her injuries still
haven't fully healed yet and her very
serious wounds could reopen if she
doesn't go back to bed but Nagant
doesn't care about any of that she
remembers deku's words and how he asked
her to please fight alongside the heroes
Nagant is determined to atone for her
past sins by living up to deku's
expectations and helping the heroes in
their time of need it is a very
desperate moment for the heroes Soul
Rock log decides to take responsibility
for lady Nagant he briefs her about the
situation on the battlefield and lets
her join the fight now of course raw
clock knows that lady Nagant was a
villain just a little while ago but
their situation is desperate and they
need all the help that they can get that
is when we're brought back to the end of
the previous chapter with Lady Nagant
taking out shigaraki's right hand in
order to stop him from using the K on
the entire UA complex her encounter with
deck who reminded her of her younger
years when she had a positive view of
heroics and wanted to change the world
for the better and so both Nagant and
the gentle decided to reform their lives
due in part to their encounter with Deku
who is just so Noble and heroic and good
that he can turn villains into Heroes
with nothing but a tiny sprinkle of
taknojutsu and okay I realize that Deku
is the main character of the story so of
course he's going to be portrayed as a
Great Hero and a great person but does
anyone else think that this is getting
to be a bit much at this point Deku
seems to have almost jesus-like Messiah
effects on people where just one
encounter with him leads them to turn
their entire lives around don't get me
wrong I do think that both gentle and
Nagant switching sides to the heroes
make sense and even if stain does it it
would also make sense but I don't think
we need to make the main reason behind
that the fact that Deku is so awesome
and inspirational that just spending
some time around him immediately makes
you a better person maybe I'm
overthinking this but I'd like to see
more complexity to these massive
character turnarounds aside from just
Deku made me see the light what do you
guys think is horikoshi laying it on a
bit thick with all the Deku worship or
are you cool with it drop me a line down
in the comments the chapter then shifts
Focus to shigaraki and his ongoing
internal struggle with all for one
during a dramatic internal conversation
with his master shigeraki says that he
knows everything he knows that all for
one brought him up to become his vessel
and that he picked him in particular
because he wanted to torture all might
with the knowledge that his own former
Master's grandson became a villain and
all for one was well on his way to
achieving his goals he had succeeded in
merging their personalities together and
he absorbed shigaraki's hatred with the
intention of using it to finally steal
one for all but shigaraki reveals that
he hated all of that and even if he
couldn't resist openly he secretly hid
his origin deep inside the depths of his
heart and eventually the part of himself
that shigaraki had hidden away was able
to take back control of his body without
all for one noticing shigaraki's true
original personality never disappeared
it never fully merged with all for one
instead it was hiding in and biting its
time until the moment came to take back
his body all for one now sees that he's
screwed up and he needs to act fast he
orders kurogiri to transport shigaraki
to his real body so that he can use his
real body to force his vessel to submit
but kurogiri doesn't obey kurogiri is
conflicted because even though all for
one is technically his master he was
always programmed to protect shigaraki
at all costs and so this order to
forcibly teleport shigaraki to all for
one seems to conflict with kurogiri's
instinct to keep shigaraki safe
shigaraki then makes it clear that he
doesn't share all for one's goals and
that he doesn't care about his master
plan shigaraki doesn't need to steal one
for all and he doesn't need to control
everything like all for one seems to be
trying to do shigaraki refuses to be all
for one's pawn and he refuses to be
corrupted by power he has never
forgotten his own main driving force his
own main goal the corruption and
hypocrisy of this world and of the hero
Society made it possible for shigaraki's
tragic childhood to exist in other words
the torment and suffering that shigaraki
experienced as a child inside his
childhood home was enabled by a
hypocritical and corrupt hero Society
the one wish that both tomurashigaraki
and tenko shimura still shared to this
day is the desire to destroy everything
that has to do with that house
everything that has to do with tanko
shimura's childhood whole and of course
the house itself is symbolic he doesn't
just mean the house as a physical object
or the people who lived inside of it
what shigaraki really means is that he
wants to destroy all the social systems
structures and institutions that made
the suffering he felt inside that home
possible on top of that many people
believe that the man we see dropping
little tenko off at home in chapter 235
was actually all for one himself the
idea here is that tenko was actually
born quirkless and that is why he never
manifested a quirk until he was over
five years old normally if someone
doesn't manifest a quirk by Age 4 they
are assumed to be quirkless tenko
manifested Decay as late as he did
because all for one had secretly
transferred it to him on the day that he
dropped him off at his house if that
theory is true then shigaraki's
Proclamation that he wants to destroy
everything associated with his house
would also include all for one himself
the man who may have visited his house
as part of his manipulative master plan
to turn tenko into a vessel for himself
shigaraki's Exposition here tells us
that he is not interested in power or
taking over the world or anything like
that it seems that in his own deranged
way he sees himself as a righteous
Avenger and a fighter for justice since
the world that he was born into was so
unjust destroying it is in some ways an
act of justice and as this internal
struggle rages inside of shigaraki on
the outside Deku forces shigaraki out of
the floating UA compound and back onto
the ground Deku knows that now that
shigaraki can use his quirks again
keeping him on board the floating UA is
just putting everyone there in immediate
life-threatening danger as the two
fighters square off against each other
on the rubble-filled surface Deku
declares that he won't let shigaraki
destroy the world but at the same time
he won't ignore the part of shigaraki
that was crying on the inside the part
of shigaraki that remains an innocent
crying little boy the real tenko shimura
before he was turned into the villain
tomura shigaraki and that is how this
chapter ends with the final battle
reaching a new stage a stage in which
Deku will have to face off against a
full power shigaraki who now has full
use of all of his quirks and shigaraki
has already begun using his quirks
because at one point both of his hands
had been shot off by Lady Nagant but by
the time that they reached the surface
shigaraki has already used super
regeneration to regenerate both of his
hands and he is ready to go the time has
come for The Ultimate Showdown full
power shigaraki with full use of all his
quirks versus full power Deku with all
of his quirks now finally unlocked this
fight will change everything and it will
determine how mha will ultimately and
now we have to talk about a serious
subject and that is the possibility that
previous generations of the greatest
hero and the greatest villain all might
and all for one will be dead by the time
this battle is over for All For One the
death foreshadowing is obvious he
already sacrificed his original Body by
rewinding it back to its prime because
he thought that he could just use
shigaraki's body as a backup but now
that shigaraki is resisting his control
all for one might end up rewinding
himself out of existence altogether with
all might things are not quite as
obvious but in the previous chapter we
did see a brief panel where tukuchi
remembers how all might walked away from
him carrying a briefcase with how
desperate the situation has become for
the heroes and hero students I just
can't picture all might sitting this
battle out completely he will likely
join the fight in some capacity and
since he is in his we can state that
decision to join the fight might result
in his making the final sacrifice to
protect his students some have even
suggested that all might may be planning
to pull the same type of sacrifice as
all for one namely using Aries Quirk to
remind himself back to his prime
temporarily but then eventually
rewinding himself out of existence this
is certainly possible but we have to
remember that unlike all for one all
might is actually friends with Arie and
he has access to her personally if Eddie
can rewind meteo's body in a way that it
restores his Quirk without rewinding him
out of existence then perhaps she could
also do the same for all might without
it resulting in his death don't get me
wrong all might could definitely die by
the time the story is over as an older
Mentor character in Shonen he certainly
wouldn't be the first to be killed off
in order to facilitate the growth of the
main character but I also wouldn't be
surprised of horikoshi spares all might
in the end one thing's for sure if
shigaraki has his way A lot of people
will die and the entire hero Society
will be destroyed the potential end of
all for one will not be an end for the
villains as a whole because shigaraki
clearly has his own unique plans and
goals that are not actually tied to the
fate of all for one so even if all for
one gets heated out of existence
shigaraki will still remain a major and
majorly overpowered threat to all of
Japan and probably the whole world he
has to be stopped one way or another and
if he isn't stopped soon many many
characters that we know and love could
die what do you guys think did this
chapter foreshadow the death of all for
one and could almight be next can tenko
shimura actually be saved like Deku
seems to be implying it is Deku going to
regret trying to save him don't forget
to leave your feedback down in the
comments below thanks again to Macarena
for sponsoring this video check them out
Link in the description if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like and of
course don't forget to subscribe to the
channel as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys